[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone i'm yoshiaki koizumi and
i'll be your guide for today's nintendo
direct
what you just saw was the first trailer
for monster hunter rise sun break
the massive expansion for monster hunter
rise
[Music]
our friends at capcom are working on
many new elements that will enhance the
experience for players of monster hunter
rise
including new stories locales
monsters
and although not touched on in the
trailer new hunting actions and quest
rank
monster hunter rise sun break
is scheduled to release as paid dlc in
summer 2022
please stay tuned for more information
in the future
all right let's see our first batch of
nintendo switch headlines
party during the day
or at night
it's almost time to parday in the mario
party superstars game along with
spaceland and peach's birthday cake
several other boards make their return
take a stroll around woody woods but
watch out for those monty moles
they'll change the board's direction
when you least expect it
travel between two islands and yoshi's
tropical island
toadette's got the star but she might
swap places with bowser at the last
second
party day and night in horrorland
that king boo statue is harmless during
the day but at night it'll swipe stars
from unsuspecting players need a break
from boards head to mount minigames and
play in mini game only courses compete
against players worldwide for the
longest win streak in survival
or work together in the cooperative
multiplayer tag match
mount minigames will have seven courses
available
all boards and minigames support online
play
so invite family friends and frenemies
and get ready for the party of a
lifetime
mario party superstars launches on the
nintendo switch system october 29th
pre-orders are available now on nintendo
eshop
a new rpg is in the cards
welcome to voice of cards
[Music]
is
at the queen's behest you'll set off on
a fantastical journey to slay a fearsome
dragon for honor and fortune
everything in this realm is represented
as cards from the protagonists
to shops
towns
and environments in this fresh take on
tabletop rpgs
you'll square off intern based card
battles where your skills and a little
bit of luck will determine the victor
[Music]
a spellbinding experience from the
creative minds of yokotaro and yosuke
saito is about to unfold
[Music]
voice of cards the isle dragon roars
launches on nintendo switch october 28th
pre-orders and a free demo will be
available today on nintendo eshop
[Music]
become a hero or an absolute disaster of
a human being
you awaken in a hotel room in the city
of revishal devoid of your memories
soon you learn that you're a detective
and get entangled in a strange murder
case in the groundbreaking role-playing
adventure disco elysium the final cut
as you interrogate people and uncover
clues internal dialogues will begin
to investigate you'll need the help of
the 24 skills living within you
your behaviors and available choices
will change depending on how you develop
these skills directly impacting how the
story progresses
[Music]
what sort of detective will you become
disco elysium the final cut launches
digitally on nintendo switch october
12th the physical version of the game
will launch early 2022. pre-orders for
the digital version begin today on
nintendo eshop
uncover more stories in hyrule warriors
age of calamity
foreign
[Music]
and about that courageous friend of
yours it seems i owe him as well
you know you're pretty good for a little
kid we'd better partner up on this don't
you think
[Music]
they won't harm
[Music]
time for the show
oh yeah
[Music]
ready
set
chocobo
start your engines and get set for a new
racing experience
races familiar final fantasy characters
like chocobo and gilgamesh to be the
first to cross the finish line
edge out the competition by using drift
boost to cut corners
magical stones called magicites are
contained inside items collect these
throughout courses to cast magic like
fire and arrow to blast away opponents
acquire magicites of the same element to
cast even more powerful spells
[Music]
each racer also has a special ability
use it at the right time to turn the
tables
[Music]
engine customization options will be
available as well as local and online
multiplayer
[Music]
up to 64 players can compete in a
bracket style tournament to determine
the racing champion
chocobo gp races exclusively onto
nintendo's witch next year
what did you think
before we show you our next video
we have some news about the last fighter
for the super smash brothers ultimate
game
mr sakurai the game's director will
reveal this fighter in the final mr
sakurai presents video on october 5th
he'll also show you how to use this
fighter so please look forward to it
[Music]
it's been about three years since the
game was released this will be the last
presentation about super smash brothers
ultimate
i hope you'll check it out
next please take a look at this
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
that was the trailer for kirby and the
forgotten land
in this new game you can freely move
around in 3d areas using familiar kirby
moves
[Music]
the setting also appears to be
mysterious filled with abandoned
structures from a past civilization
what lies in store for kirby
the game is scheduled to release in
spring 2022
we hope you'll look forward to kirby's
new adventure
next we have this to show you
please take a look
[Music]
do
[Music]
since its launch in 2020 the animal
crossing new horizons game has been
enjoyed by many players around the world
new free content will arrive in november
[Music]
in preparation for its release we will
be airing an animal crossing new
horizons direct in october
in it we'll go over the content in more
detail
[Music]
please be on the lookout for the air
date of this presentation
[Music]
let's move on to more nintendo switch
headlines
two games one game update and lots of
fun
four
more free content is coming to the mario
golf super rush game
koopa troopa enters the fairway as a
playable character
dish out tricky shots and dashes to mess
with the competition
ninji will also be playable
take advantage of ninji's blinding speed
to outpace opponents
two courses are also being added
these additions will come swinging in as
a free software update later today
[Music]
what's this
an invitation
you're invited to live in a magical
world with mickey mouse and dozens of
disney characters
spend time with disney friends
craft your own whimsical costumes and
furniture and explore delightful disney
themed worlds
all downloadable content from the
original nintendo 3ds version is
included disney magical world 2
enchanted edition soars onto nintendo
switch this holiday
[Music]
a beloved star wars game is coming to
nintendo switch blast off to captivating
planets and join forces with jedi droids
and outcasts in this blend of action
role playing and adventure
will you use the force for good or will
you be lured to the dark side
your choices determine the galaxy's fate
in star wars knights of the old republic
launching on nintendo switch november
11th pre-orders begin today on nintendo
eshop
there's one thing you must always
remember
stay human
this is the city humanity's last
stronghold against a virus that turns
people into the undead in the cloud
version of dying light 2 stay human
you'll need to master both parkour and
tactical combat to survive in this
brutal open world action rpg explore
alone or with up to three other players
in online co-op as you unravel the dark
secrets of those in power during the day
then plunder the layers of the infected
at night your decisions will shape the
story but they'll also have consequences
no matter where your actions lead you
there's one thing you must always
remember stay human
while you're at it take the prequel on
the go in dying light platinum edition
scavenge for supplies craft weapons and
face hordes of the infected in a
post-apocalyptic open world
dying light to stay human cloud version
launches on nintendo switch february 4th
2022 a free demo will also launch the
same day on nintendo eshop
dying light platinum edition comes to
nintendo switch october 19th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
utility morality or liberty
in triangle strategy a fiery chronicle
of war presented in stunning hd 2d
my apologies your actions will lead you
through a riveting story that changes
based on the decisions you make
in the end where will your conviction
guide you
you have gone to the one place i cannot
follow
in response to the survey about the demo
released in february of this year the
game has been fine-tuned with the focus
on elements that received lots of
feedback
these include adjustments to the
difficulty
improvements to on-screen visuals
camera angle controls
the ability to review previous dialogue
[Music]
and streamlined game flow and loading
times
more details are now available on
nintendo.com
splendid
triangle strategy will launch on
nintendo switch march 4th 2022.
pre-orders begin today on nintendo isha
[Music]
you are faced with overwhelming power
your highest priority it should be
simply to survive
there may be a very small opportunity to
escape
don't let your guard down
samus aaron the most powerful bounty
hunter in the galaxy embarks on a new
mission to the uncharted planet zdr
for objectives
confirm whether the deadly x parasite
still exists and figure out why the emmy
research robots in search of it have
mysteriously gone dark
early readings reveal that planet zdr is
divided into multiple environments
each with its own elements
and organisms
remnants of the mighty chozo
civilization are also scattered
throughout including evidence that the
chozo may have once called the planet
their home
visit
metroid.nintendo.com to read metroid
dread report volume 8 for a detailed
account of the terrain and life forms
you may encounter in the metroid dread
game
be sure to view the other metroid dread
reports there as well
you'll want to prepare yourself for the
dangers that lie ahead
metroid dread launches on nintendo
switch october 8th pre-orders are
available now on nintendo eshop
how was that
up next we have news about nintendo
switch online
many people have been using nintendo
switch online since it launched in
september 2018.
in addition to the current membership
we'll be adding a new membership plan
[Music]
as a part of this new plan's content
[Music]
you'll be able to play a collection of
nintendo 64 games
the nintendo 64 system launched 25 years
ago
i think this system gave many players
their first 3d gaming experiences
as well as intense four-player
multiplayer action
with nintendo's switch up to four people
can play select nintendo 64 games
locally or online
also with this new membership plan in
addition to the nintendo 64 games
you can play a collection of games from
sega's genesis system
[Music]
this means you'll be able to play these
classic games whenever and wherever
you'd like
the new plan will include all elements
of the base nintendo switch online
membership
well as the ability to play the included
nintendo 64 in genesis games
this is nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack
[Music]
this new membership plan will be added
in late october
[Music]
of course you'll still be able to
continue using the existing plans
[Music]
also those who have an existing
membership plan can change over to the
new plan
[Music]
we'll share more details about this new
membership plan at a later time
including the exact release date and
pricing information
for now however we'd like to announce
the games that will be available when it
launches
you'll be able to play the nintendo 64
game shown here
[Music]
as well as these genesis games
we'll also continue adding more nintendo
64 games such as the legend of zelda
majora's mask and f0x
as well as other nintendo 64 and genesis
games going forward
[Music]
furthermore we've prepared nintendo 64
and genesis controllers to ensure the
games can be played with the same style
controls from their original releases
both can be used wirelessly
these controllers will be available for
purchase by any nintendo switch online
member
[Music]
we hope you'll look forward to this new
membership plan
nintendo switch online plus expansion
pack
let's see a few more nintendo switch
headlines
there's plenty to play in these
collections
cyberpunk meets fantasy in this
three-game collection of cult classic
rpgs
as a shadow runner mercenary you'll
explore a dystopian future where magic
has reawakened and fantasy creatures
have come back to life
immersive branching narratives
skill-based character growth
and gripping turn-based tactical combat
await in shadowrun trilogy launching on
nintendo switch next year
[Music]
the perpetual struggle against count
dracula continues
castlevania advance collection brings
together four classic castlevania games
with deathly beautiful graphics and
hauntingly epic music
the rewind
quick save and button mapping features
will also vamp up or ramp up your fight
against evil
all regional versions of each game as
well as a gallery mode with never before
seen artwork are included castlevania
advance collection launches on nintendo
switch later today
an almighty classic returns
[Music]
the classic super nes game actrazer
returns on nintendo switch now
remastered in hd as the lord of light an
almighty god only you can save mankind
from the forces of tanzra the lord of
dark you'll wage war in two phases
first strike down monsters in the
side-scrolling action phase to liberate
the lands from the grasp of evil master
swordsmanship and magic to vanquish all
who stand in your path
then cultivate the lands you've
liberated in the world building creation
phase
it's up to you to decide which
structures will be destroyed to make way
for new ones creating a flourishing
civilization
as you do so your powers will increase
giving you an edge in both phases
alternate between the original and
rearranged versions of the beloved
soundtrack and enjoy brand new music
new stages and new boss battles also
await
actraiser renaissance descends onto
nintendo switch later today
a new chapter is about to unfold
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
how's everything
there are still a few more announcements
in today's nintendo direct
oh miyamoto-san
what brings you in i wanted to make an
announcement so i was hoping i could
step in oh of course
hi everyone i'm shigeru miyamoto
we've previously announced that i have
been working with the hollywood movie
studio illumination and its ceo and
producer chris meledandresun
who are known for movies like despicable
me and sync in making a full-length
animated mario movie for the big screen
today i wanted to announce its
theatrical release timing
[Music]
the movie will be released in theaters
and holiday 2022
the release date for north america is on
december 21st and will be announcing
release dates for japan europe and other
regions at a later time it'll be a while
longer until we can share a glimpse of
mario in action on the big screen but
today i also wanted to reveal our key
cast members who will be voicing mario
and his friends in the movie
first of course is mario
who will be played by chris pratt
he's so cool
mario will be talking a lot in the movie
please look forward to mario as
performed by the very talented chris son
next princess peach will be played by
anya taylor joy
i can't wait to see a very spirited
princess peach
[Music]
mario's little brother luigi will be
played by charlie day
i'm excited for you to see this timid
sibling appear on screen
bowser will be played by the one and
only jack black
i'm expecting a monster performance by
jackson
the comedian keegan michael key will be
playing toad
i'm looking forward to great comedic
moments
[Music]
even though this is a mario movie donkey
kong will also be making an appearance
he will be played by seth rogen
i'm eager for you to see a humorous
donkey kong by satsang
[Music]
and of course charles martine
who has voiced mario and many more
nintendo characters in our games over
the years is also involved
and will be appearing in surprise cameos
in the movie
[Music]
we also have more incredible talent
joining the film to play some of our
other beloved characters
that is all i can share with you today
about the mario movie
this is a very collaborative project
between illumination and nintendo we've
all been coming up with all sorts of
ideas and i myself am enjoying a
creative process that is a little bit
different from making games it may be a
while until we can share more updates
but i hope you'll look forward to it
back to you
please look forward to mario's adventure
jumping into the world of motion
pictures
next we'd like to show you this
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
hello everyone i'm a researcher from the
squid research lab i've been
meticulously studying the mysterious
squids that can transform into humanoid
form
what you just saw was the latest
research footage from splatoon 3.
allow me to share a bit of what we know
so far
3 takes place in splatsville
it's known as the city of chaos
centered around splattsville are the
splatlands a place long inhabited by
advanced sea creatures such as squids
and octopuses
buildings spanning several generations
are crammed into the city creating its
distinctive culture
in the splatlands turf war appears to be
a popular activity
its basic rules are unchanged two four
player teams compete against each other
to ink the most area
however
the trend seems to have undergone a
major shift with the existence of new
main and special weapons confirmed in
the footage
in the latter portion of the footage we
were able to observe activities from
story mode the single player campaign
return of the
mammalians meaning the reappearance of
mammals
appears to be the theme of story mode
this time around
what could this possibly mean in a world
where all mammals except for two cats
have vanished
[Music]
it appears that there's still a lot to
uncover
but we'll continue with our research and
keep you updated once more results
become available
please look forward to more
splatoon 3
[Music]
updates to come
see you next time
[Music]
so
what did you think
splatoon 3 taking place in a new world
is scheduled to release in 2022
please look forward to future updates
okay this is the last trailer we have to
show you today please take a look
here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
bad boys
[Music]
it seems i'm unfashionably late
but i'm ready to give you everything you
want
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what you just saw was the latest trailer
for bayonetta 3.
we announced this game in 2017 and we
thank you for your patience
this game will launch next year
[Music]
we hope you look forward to bayonetta's
new encounters
that's all for today's nintendo direct
thank you for watching
[Music]
you